hey everybody welcome back to the
GameSpot stage I'm joined by two lovely
gentlemen Al and Chris and you guys are
from wargaming how's it going how'd you
feel about tanks I'm surprised how about
how about a whole world populated by
tanks with that that make you happy oh
we actually spare Mike on you I'll relax
if you can speak for Chris while he
makes himself up that'd be great right
I'm gonna dress my questions to you show
her let's let's do it very good
brilliant well guys no that's fine I
guess my father should remind you anyway
anyway you guys have brought a game with
with you defrosted look at it it's World
of Tanks but maybe not as you know it
here it is on a tablet like you like 85
million that's great okay okay so light
medium and heavy tanks yeah I think
we're the enemy our choose a light tank
but if you want to sort of prowl around
on the back with a big gun and then just
slide people from a distance go for a
heavy with this game it was important
that we made it kind of we want people
to get into the action a lot quicker so
instead of 15 vs. 15 I'm a big map it's
7 vs. 7 on a small amount think rugby
sevens versus you know 4k and
we also left out the artillery which are
great for the PC game but they make no
sense in a mobile context gotcha
and so the maps are smaller the teams
the teams are smaller we basically
accelerate people into the action so
instead of an eight-minute game it's a
three or four minute game so they'll
write whether you're you know sitting on
the loo or commuting or just waiting for
your bus
you can basically dip into your mobile
and get your fix fantastic so how does
it so what you're just going through the
selection process at the moment yeah
well let's choose a famous American
Chiang the m4 Sherman from the Normandy
celebrations and we actually saw one of
these rolling along a beach and they
look formidable so it's a great
all-rounder it's a medium tank so it can
do a little bit of scouting a little bit
of sniping as with the main game you've
got various customizable options you can
use you can have a bigger gun we're men
of course it's all about having the
biggest possible gun so put a big gun on
it and then let's get in and start doing
some killing yeah if you want you can
have a bigger engine but yeah it's
basically about having a bigger gun all
right hit that battle button mate let's
go in yeah so we basically just tested
this in the Nordic region where it
placed number three in the in the
AppStore so that's a fantastic result
but the most interesting statistic is
that the average game times were like 70
plus minutes now that's huge
Wow yeah exactly so it's sort of like I
think most people think mobile games can
be a little bit disposable you know yes
they're great fun but they don't have
any you know real depth and immersion
and so that our guys have really focused
on taking a proper fully immersive
action game onto a mobile platform yeah
and we think they've done it so we're
going into a map here called fort
despair all of the maps for World of
Tanks blitz we've had many by the way if
you're watching home or wondering what
what devices oh and here we go we're in
games so it's just sort of you know a
dry desert II rocky type of a thing so
the biggest challenge for the mobile
game when you're doing a full action
game is control interface so we
basically experimented with various
options and one we've come up with we
think is fine however if you disagree
it's customizable you can basically move
the icons around on the screen you can
stretch them and shrink them so just
enjoy direction with your left thumb
there right
left and then the view with the right
and then yet again
the gosh you know the original game
relies on keyboard and mouse we've
basically used a few shortcuts to help
make things a bit easier for you so the
main one is the auto zoom so instead of
having to zoom in and out and get your
ranging right the game takes know that
for you right so we've got an enemy
they're highlighted in red and the auto
zoom has gone in and then we've hit the
fire button and the shells gone in
you'll see the red circle basically that
reflects the reload time that's totally
accurate that would take that tank that
long to reload that shell in battle
that's all properly simulate it that is
that frame Chris the pressure high
pressure live on air I'm actually gonna
dismiss you you are fired give me the
bloody pad I'll play now I'm kidding
this is way better than I am sorry mate
you forgot my question because he died
I'm gonna put me right off if you could
not die never great so basically you
were killed by an AI correct well I know
these this is a live game oh yeah
amazingly even though it's about 4 in
the morning back over in Scandinavia ok
there's still about 200 people but for
whatever reason are up playing World of
Tanks blitz oh no that's cool there's no
AI BOTS in the game it's almost all
players a team based seven against seven
absolutely guys will you let your team
down there afraid so do you want us to
go back in now let's go back in let's
keep playing I want to see more he's a
different tank I don't know whichever
one you Francis see what it looks like
when heavy go for a heavy yeah a nice
big heavy
let's stay American we're in America
let's upset people here we go we've got
the German tanks in there obviously a
lot of people relate to the German tanks
because they were famous to Panther the
tiger they're brilliant tanks a little
bit over engineered like their car so
they do break down and the American ones
are very good for mobility yep they were
basically using chassis and suspension
that were made by the Ford car factory
yeah they're really comfortable to ride
in the Russian tanks they're really an
exercise in basically you know just
massive numbers so they got them off the
production line really quickly into the
front line yeah they also pioneered the
sloping armor which basically makes the
shells bounce off so yeah I don't know
it's impossible to say which are the
best tanks but I have a slight bias
towards rough
Christel Christmas your favorite ones to
play with then which surely I like being
a scout there's no space Delphine is a
young light mobile lab so it's probably
quite a quick runner quite often your
personality Drive okay so what tank
would I be then heavy if we work
together and by the way you can work
together we would be great yeah so yeah
he'll be running around lighting up the
map showing where the enemies were okay
you'd be going into a support position
waiting for me to kind of like get up
onto the ridge at the back zoom in and
snipe and take them out so okay we're in
three two one battle time here we go so
good luck we we didn't we didn't
actually highlight the chat facility but
you've got in-game chat the key to all
of wargaming's games is that they are
team based yeah so it's very difficult
to actually win this game on your own if
you try and be alone I mean no pressure
is only is only about 2,000 people
watching you so don't worry about the
pressure so yeah I'm almost certain
we're gonna have a win stick with your
teammate right he's he's a nippy lad
he's a scout a diamond means a scout and
then a triangle means a tank destroyer
they're pretty nasty they've got massive
frontal armor and really powerful hype
gun to high velocity shells so they will
take you out if you see one that's a
heavy there so let's try and take him
out there is good shot they go he's
retreated behind the wall he reloads and
then he's gonna swipe out again oh
you'll get a lot of this kind of
tactical play zigzagging across each
other what happens make sure you don't
hit your team I say what happens if you
do friendly fire base a slap on the
wrist okay and you know you might swear
at you in game they will build damages
Hank oh yeah you'll take damage just
like you would repeatedly damage your
own player then you know one of our
game's masters might just take you out
and say look you know this isn't good
yeah you should go wrong people yeah
you'll get a bad reputation and you'll
see that in your rankings yeah you know
you might be left out a platoon okay so
yeah
good yeah you've got three different
shell types here you've got standard
shells which will work for most
situations but if you come up against a
heavy tank you're going to need to go to
armor-piercing okay so they basically
they tape her a lot more quicker they're
a bit more pointy and then we'll go
inside and then you know the the show
will explode yeah and then if you're
dealing with a weak armored vehicle like
a tank destroyer they've got massive
guns but they've got weak armor then you
load a high explosive and that will go
in and basically take the night and one
or two shots we could probably take this
guy down
pretty soon over here there you go
training and it's paying off right so
there's a red bar filling up in the
middle of the game now that basically
means there's two ways to win the game
kill all the enemy or capture their flag
that's what we've got going on right now
is the enemy team are in the process of
capturing the flag so we're gonna sneak
sneak up on this Ridge and hopefully
we'll get a view of the tank that's
actually inside the zone if you want
we're gonna need to rush into the to the
flag area if you can get one hit on the
guy that's basically capturing the flag
then it'll reset that count down to a
hundred and so it'll count up a gassy
we've got about a minute left on stage
so let's see what we can do in a minute
Chris no pressure absolutely so what
just to wrap things up then so this this
is globally available I'm doing the
twenty six people need to go to wot
which is World of Tanks wot blitz calm
yeah and unregister and remember this is
free-to-play
sweetie play this is free-to-play
team-based mobile tank gaming coming to
an iPhone near you from June the 26th
June the 27th do you say 26 26 we were
actually able to reset unbelievably
you've done well we did it yes nice nice
work well done excellent so I won't
rehire you Chris I mean a ruler Chris
today people back on the team back
yes Justin no more try to win this nice
and calm take a few more shots in time
for a few more shots look about zooming
in auto zoom that's a t-34 I think
sloping armor on the front there come on
Chris come on Chris there we go
that's a good hair good hits put back
let's put back all right here we go here
we go I think we got this guys keep your
job whatever happens remember go come on
he's right there
okay so he's right there no pressure
come to me now no pressure
thank you out dude coward he's a coward
yeah I think that's it once again people
wot blitz calm doing the toy really
wonderful work wonderful work gives me a
pleasure having you pal Chris yeah we go
there in the end